buenas noches muchas gracias muchas
gracias buenas noches
[Aplausos]
entonces gracias buenas noches
bueno el congresista john no es el
congresista john lewis antes de su
fallecimiento escribió que la democracia
no es un estado es un acto y lo que él
quería decir era que la democracia
estadounidense no está garantizada
solamente es tan fuerte como nuestra
voluntad para luchar por ella
para cuidarla para nunca darla por
sentado
proteger nuestra democracia requiere
lucha requiere sacrificio
pero también hay dicha en ello
y hay progreso porque nosotros el pueblo
tenemos el poder de construir un mejor
futuro
[Aplausos]
y cuando nuestra democracia nuestra
propia democracia estuvo en el tarjetón
en esta elección
con el alma de eeuu en juego y con el
mundo observando a ustedes ustedes nos
permitieron tener un nuevo día un nuevo
renacer para eeuu
[Aplausos]
[Música]
al equipo de nuestra campaña los
voluntarios
este equipo extraordinario muchas
gracias por reunir más gente que nunca
antes al proceso demócrata al proceso
democrático
[Aplausos]
y por hacer que esa victoria fuera
posible a los trabajadores electorales a
los funcionarios electorales en todo
nuestro país que han trabajado
incansablemente para asegurarse que cada
voto sea contado nuestra nación les debe
mucha gratitud
[Aplausos]
y ustedes han protegido la integridad de
nuestra democracia y el pueblo
estadounidense
que constituye nuestro hermoso país
muchas gracias por salir en cifras
récord para hacer que sus voces sean
oídas
a nana y yo sé que las épocas han sido
desafiantes especialmente los últimos
meses el pesar el dolor la tristeza las
preocupaciones y las luchas pero también
hemos presenciado el coraje de todos
ustedes su resiliencia y la generosidad
de sus espíritus por cuatro años
ustedes marcharon ustedes se organizaron
en nombre de la igualdad y la justicia
en nombre de nuestras vidas en nombre de
nuestro planeta y ahí votaron
y nos entregaron un mensaje muy claro
ustedes eligieron la esperanza y
eligieron la unidad la decencia a la
ciencia y si la verdad
ustedes eligieron a joe biden como el
nuevo presidente de los eeuu de américa
[Aplausos]
y joe es un sanador una persona que trae
unidad una mano probado una mano firme
una persona cuya propia experiencia de
perdida le da una sensación de propósito
que nos ayudará como nación a reclamar
nuestro propio sentido de propósito y
exigir con una gran corazón que ama es
su amor por hitler que será un increíble
primera dama
es a su amor por hunter y por ashley y
por sus nietos y por toda la familia
baile
[Aplausos]
y aunque cuando conocí a yo como
vicepresidente realmente lo conocí como
padre amante de bou un amigo querido a
quien recordamos hoy ya mi esposo doc
[Aplausos]
ya nuestros hijos con miel y mi hermana
maya y a toda nuestra familia los amo a
todos más de lo que pudiese expresar
[Aplausos]
estamos muy agradecidos con joe jordan
por darnos la bienvenida en su familia
en este increíble viaje y a la mujer que
es más responsable por mi presencia acá
hoy a mi madre llama lago para liniers
que siempre está en nuestros corazones
cuando ella llegó de la india a los 19
años
realmente no imaginaba este momento pero
ella creyó profundamente en eeuu donde
momentos como este son posibles entonces
pienso en ello estoy pensando en ella y
pienso también en las generaciones de
mujeres mujeres negras
asiáticas blancas latinas nativas
estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
que a lo largo de la historia del país
han pavimentado el camino para que este
momento de esta noche ocurra mujeres que
lucharon y se sacrificaron sacrificaron
tanto el nombre de la igualdad y la
libertad y la justicia para todos
incluyendo a las mujeres negras quienes
frecuentemente son ignoradas
pero comprueban constantemente que son
la columna vertebral de nuestra
democracia
en todas las mujeres que han trabajado
para asegurar y proteger el derecho a
votar por más de un siglo
hace 100 años con la enmienda 1950 y
cinco años con los derechos el acta de
votación ahora en 2020 con una nueva
generación de mujeres en nuestro país
que pusieron sus a gestores y
continuaron la lucha por su derecho
fundamental a votar ya ser oídas
[Aplausos]
esta noche hago una reflexión sobre su
lucha por sobre su determinación y la
fortaleza de su perspectiva para poder
ver lo que puede ser sin las cargas de
lo que ya ha sido y yo estoy en los
hombros de ellas que testamento que gran
venta venta estamento a joe también
tener la audacia de vencer una de las
barreras más sustanciales que existe en
nuestro país y elegir a una mujer como
vicepresidente
[Aplausos]
pero aunque yo sea la primera mujer en
este cargo no seré la última
porque cada pequeña chica que está
viendo hoy esto puede ver que este es un
país de posibilidades ya los niños de
nuestro país sin importar su género
nuestro país les ha enviado un mensaje
claro sueñen con ambiciones lideren con
sus convicciones y vean
en una forma en que otros puedan no
verlos simplemente porque nunca han
visto que suceda antes pero sepan que
aplaudiremos cada paso de su camino
en el pueblo estadounidense sin importar
por quien hayan votado yo me esforzaré
por ser una vicepresidenta así como fue
joe para el presidente obama leal
honesta y preparada despertando me cada
día pensando en ustedes y en sus
familias porque ahora es cuando el
trabajo verdadero empieza el trabajo
realmente fuerte el trabajo necesario el
buen trabajo el trabajo esencial salvar
vidas vencer esta epidemia reconstruir
nuestra economía para que funcione para
las familias trabajadores para acabar
con el racismo sistemático en nuestra
sociedad y nuestro país combatir la
crisis climática unir a nuestro país y
sanar el alma de nuestra nación
y el camino que nos sigue no será fácil
pero eeuu está lista
y también yo y yo estamos listos
[Aplausos]
hemos elegido a un presidente que
representa a lo mejor de nosotros un
líder
que el mundo respetara
y que nuestros niños observarán un
comandante en jefe' que respetará a
nuestras tropas y mantendrá nuestro país
a salvo y un presidente para todos los
estadounidenses
[Aplausos]